you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network this is a by
American history podcast each week I
macho Dave Anthony this is I like this
threat you can't handle what you're
doing breathe face destroy yourself Jays
friend Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be it's not
it's not mas macho no nope s picot
emelita veto no safe because no because
uh because of salsa
you know pequeno am Anita little play
and called it quote is jam-packed
Jim I'm the [ __ ] hippo God Dave okay
names Garrity but it's good is it for
fun and this is not gonna come
particularly now hit him with the puppy
you both present sick arguments dad my
friend
Gareth we have upcoming dates do it
I said Gareth yeah correcting me when I
say the right way no sorry if I've been
hurt the dollop will be an Irvine on
August 15th San Diego on August 16 San
Jose on September 11th Sacramento on
September 13th Boise on September 14th
and Madison on October 18th Milwaukee on
October 20th and then we go to Europa
well be in Stockholm on November 10th we
will be in Oslo on November 12th I say
it right yeah I will probably probably
doing it wrong
Amsterdam November 13th Glasgow November
I write Glasgow Glasgow grad school
November 4 I just caught you throw a
football through the window the glass
school ah I just caught stab town
November 14th man Chet Scotland is the
stabbing capital of the world you know
that I didn't know it but it's one of
those things where you hear it you go of
course
Manchester November 15th somebody gave
me tickets domitius United London
November 16th Birmingham laning and
November 19th
Cardiff November 20th Dublin November
21st and Copenhagen November 24th boom I
will leading up to that I will be on
tour this summer I was in North Carolina
this last weekend it was a great time
Dave will tell you held someone's bag
this weekend I'll be at the Vermont
comedy club in Burlington Vermont that's
June 13th through the 15th I'll be at
the comedy attic in Bloomington Illinois
June 20th through the 22nd comedy off
Broadway Lexington Kentucky June 27th
through the 29th July 19th through the
20th he'll be at laughs Boston which is
in Boston actually Acme comedy club
Minneapolis Minnesota July 30th through
the 3rd of August improv Denver Colorado
August 9th through the 11th and then the
Fremont Abbi is Seattle Washington
August 17th and it'll all culminate with
an album taping
comedy on state August 24th but I will
actually be there August 22nd through
the 24th leading up to that if you want
to come check it out oh yeah one more
thing oh there I'm doing a thing
with my buddy Ron click own which is an
epic livestream to save net neutrality
it's actually tomorrow Monday June 11th
but my guess is you can go to epic
livestream dot-com and be a part of this
it's the fight for net neutrality and
yeah I'm sure you can go there and check
it out so a couple of podcasts to to
push I have a podcast called The West
Wing thing with Josh Olsen is an
oscar-nominated writer and we talked
about the West Wing and how it has
affected governing and it turns out
that's not that great and then there's a
really really [ __ ] funny podcast oh I
saw that clip you put up called success
Express right a success Express pod it's
really [ __ ] funny okay I want people
to check it out I don't even know the
guys I just it's just [ __ ] hilarious
well then we should also say that James
Adomian has the under culture I don't
know if you've heard any of that but
that is dynamite
yes insanity oh and then I have one
called point versus point and if you
want to watch any of the video of us
doing this podcast for whatever reason
if you want to see what we look like
which is a letdown I'll tell you that
much yeah you can go to the all things
comedy youtube channel which is now up
yeah we're a key this podcast is
sponsored by Casper mmm
Casper's new hybrid mattresses getting
my data Casper are you yes
[ __ ] yeah you are are they having a
hybrid mattress that combines the
pressure relief of their award-winning
foam with durable yet gentle springs now
you have a Casper I do and that's why
you're getting your data Casper yes
because it's awesome thank you think
into it don't you you do in the morning
there's two sync spots in your bed I
don't think one from you and one from
your heavier cat he yeah he's lost a
tremendous amount away he still
outweighs you he's lost a lot of weight
we are almost we almost would if we were
to box we would be in the same class
Casper products are cleverly designed to
mimic human curves and probably cap
providing supportive comfort for all
kinds of bodies including very large
cats as you know Casper mattress
combines multiple supportive memory
foams for a quality sleep service with
the right amounts of both sink and
bounce
and there's a lot of bounce and a lot of
sink you me both baby breathable design
helps you sleep cool and regulate your
body temperature throughout the night is
that is that how you feel I would say
there are a couple times the night I
wake up and I go regulated tempo it
comes in that box and it opens up right
and that's the best that's all downhill
from there let's be honest it's the best
thing has to be returns if you're not
completely satisfied you can be sure of
your purchase the caster's 100 night
risk-free sleep on it trial so get fifty
dollars towards select mattresses by
visiting casper calm a slash dollop
using a dollop at checkout that's casper
calm slash dollop in using dollop at
checkout terms and conditions apply we
are of course also brought to you by fab
fit fun gareth the 2019 fabfitfun summer
box is on sale now let's do it
yes i mean we're both fans yeah well our
ladies are fans your mom is my lady
thanks comfortable the last one they had
a purple facemask
oh yeah so i went in my wife was opening
up and I went in and I tried to reach
reaching to pick something up yes you
slapped my hand away always get us this
is my box it does do something to it
really does it does something to the
brain it does something to the brain
yeah then I've seen it not just with my
mother but with other women and they are
it's it's it's like meat it's like a
caveman has meat so if you love
discovery new products if you are a
beauty and fashion maven constantly on
the hunt for the next big thing ever
read about or spot something online that
you've always wanted to try but never
have then you must try a fab fit fun
like we said it's a seasonal
subscription box delivered four times a
year with full-size beauty fashion home
fitness and wellness products for just
49.99 a box full size products no
samples of anything every box guaranteed
to have over 200 dollars in retail vo
the 2019 summer box retail value is
between 269 and 467
fantastic value many products individual
value is more than the entire box great
for discovering new brands and products
as I said so sign up for fabfitfun today
these boxes always sell out use our code
dollop to get $10 off your first box and
go to fabfitfun calm to sign up and
start getting the box for a life
well-lived use promo code opt you get
$10 off your first box that's over $200
for $39.99 go to fabfitfun calm and use
code dollop to get $10 off your first
fab fit fun box and then of course well
say your uh say you're a guy oh wow it's
been awhile since I heard about this guy
and say you went to another country and
and the leaders there didn't want it
this is the same guy normally or this is
a different person and then say in C you
were there in thousands of people
protested your you just being there that
in thousands and thousands of people
okay so I know what this tested you and
say your kids went to a pub and and and
bought around forever but in left
without paying I'd say you're that kind
of person well talk space because I
think I know the real good no tax base
is really good a situation for you it is
an online therapy company look we all
need someone to talk to especially if
you're the person I just talked about a
person who can support us through the
rough patches or even everyday ups and
downs of life that's the talk space
that's where tuck space comes in it's an
online therapy company that makes tech
makes taking care of your mental health
more affordable and convenient than ever
before simply provide your preferences
for therapy and talk space will match
one of 4000 therapists the very same day
send your therapist unlimited text audio
picture video message from anywhere at
any time and no matter what you're going
through you're not alone join more than
1 million people who feel happy with
talks because we've got a lot of people
who said many people yeah that said this
is actually really really helped me out
especially people are in places it can't
or else just you don't have the time or
you don't you not in a place where you
feel like you can you know what I mean
there's label that uncomfortable yeah
it's convenient it's easy to use it's
affordable the stock space has more than
4,000 licensed therapists who are
experienced in addressing the challenges
we all face to match with your private
therapist for a fraction of the price of
traditional therapy go to talk space.com
make sure to use the code dog to get
your first week free and show your
support for this show that's dollop and
talk space.com mmm anything else want to
say anything talk about I think I know
the family you're talking about sorry
September 9th 1890 year of our Lord
Jesus Christ Harland
David Sanders was born on a farm near
Henryville Indiana okay it's about 50
miles north of the Kentucky border okay
well I really don't know how this
country is set up here what was a
different time right now we can tell you
that in it based on what I just said
Indian is above Kentucky right but do
they touch today yeah it moved okay
let's see that shocks me that's the same
thing with like people like it's you
know it's right here like how Pittsburgh
or uh Pennsylvania is near Ohio I was
like what you've never looked at a map
I think iíve looked at a map yeah even
today I had to look what Vermont was I
was like oh like if someone put a map in
front of you and said label every state
we're gonna do that it would not know
we're gonna do that during him that'll
be that'll be for Patriots that's it's
gonna be like a me go there's gonna be
eight Indiana and then after that we'll
do the world
oh dude go [ __ ] you wandering the world
like so all this is China I think so I'm
not sure so he described a Henryville as
a community where quote later he did a
man usually had only one suit that he
got to get married in then he put it
away and didn't have it on again until
they laid him out in a casket that's
perfect that's the perfect amount of
suits it is one
two times and one of those times you
dead yeah perfect yeah I know nice his
father Wilbur was a butcher his mother
was a Christian I was strict Christian
constantly warning her children of the
evils of alcohol tobacco you know
gambling right so fun mom
his parents had two more kids a boy and
a girl when he was five his father died
came home with a fever and that was it
was out yep tell you what someone comes
home with a fever you like I don't like
it yeah it's not gonna happen it's
before 1904 sure figure out his mother
Margaret then had to go work long hours
at a local canning factory I read
somewhere that she would sometimes do
three day shifts in a row but I don't
know if that was a shift yeah she would
have to be the canning factory Shockers
well back then nobody cared just just
work yeah it's not like today where
people are like hey we want to have you
aware and we'll pay you a lot of money
to not work a ton of hours exact times
were they're like you should still work
for every industry in America at five
Harlan started to look after siblings
because his dad was dead his mom's
working cooking the meals doing the
whole thing quote we didn't have any
babysitter but we got along fine we
knowed enough not to burn down the house
so I'm guessing that there wasn't a lot
of time for English uh well yeah I mean
doesn't sound like it really yeah that's
fine yeah when I understand yeah when I
was 12 his mom remarried and they moved
to Indianapolis he did not get along
with a stepfather in within a year he
left home how old is eight he's 12 he's
12 okay he's out right for three years
he bounced around Indiana working
various jobs a farmhand horse carriage
painter streetcar fare collector even
went to school for a bit when he's
living on his own but he dropped out in
the sixth grade
quote the teacher started us on algebra
she kept saying x equals the unknown
quantity that didn't sound no good to me
if there was none on quantity I wanted
to find out about it else I didn't want
to mess with it but so that's where me
and the school parted this is where me
and him come together
yes spirit out yeah the guy who doesn't
know that Kentucky's next door
like this in 1906 at 16 he lied about
his age and and enlisted in the army I'm
14 that'll do
he was deployed to Cuba but he got
severe seasickness during the trip to
the island and that resulted in him
losing 41 pounds
oh my god it's 16 that one item what are
you wait you went like what 1 I know
that I didn't say like then probably 140
didn't say how much he weighs losing
like a third of your body mass I mean
it's not great okay he hated the
military his main task was taking care
of mules well I wonder what part of the
military he didn't like that's the fun
part
yeah for sure after 4 months he was
honorably discharged ok
I read somewhere that they found out it
would help what age he was but who knows
right they might have just been he'd
just got a really good job with the
mules right get out of here you peaked
well he moved Alabama and got a job
cleaning a locomotive engines so that's
cool yeah for sure and then he worked
his way up to a steam engineer Stoker
which is known as a fireman so I think
that's where you're throwing that :
alright ok yeah I was there he said he
picked up the habit of swearing like a
sailor which would continue for the rest
of his life
nice eye 1909 Harlan met and married
Josephine King in 1910 they had a
daughter Margaret so he's 19 years old
he's got a kid sure just the way it's
supposed to be yeah in 1912 they had a
son Harland jr. Harley became heavily
involved in the Brotherhood of
locomotive firemen and an engineer man
which upset his bosses who were Union
Buster's okay so the Union okay
they used a brief recurrence of his
motion sickness to fire him so he would
get motion sickness once in a while and
so when he got motion sick we will get
motion sickness from being on the train
oh boy so he was really it's not a great
job for him but no it was the job he
wanted is this the story of dream I mean
so after that he got a job in railroad
track maintenance but he didn't like it
he wanted to work on the train just
getting seasick he's seasick Oh God
but he wanted work on trains because
they gave him quote the feeling I was
sitting
on top of the world mm-hmm it's a
different time man it's a different era
everybody all the kids back then wanted
order being on a train was the thing
right there you know yeah it's different
yeah so he quit that job
and left to be a fight to get a fireman
job in Virginia he goes without his
family okay
interesting maybe he was gonna bring him
back how long later or sure whatever but
his wife was upset with him yeah and
said he's just not it's not normally how
it goes it's not know well what if
you're on a baseball team yeah that's
different you come home it's just not
the same thing
so it's not the same thing as like
Buster Posey no it's not no unless
there's something glaring about Buster
Posey I don't know well sometimes he's
gone oh yeah that works we travel for
work it's different you don't go I'm
starting a new life in another town I'll
come back that's why I say to my wife
every time I go to a tour gig
that's a weird exit that's just how I
keep him on edge it's a cool catchphrase
come on edge his wife was upset with him
and said he was quote jumping around
from job to job too much like a flea
his brother-in-law sent him a letter
when he was in Virginia and that's how
he learned his wife had taken the kids
and moved out torn down their home and
gave away their furniture to neighbors
Jesus Christ that's a she's out when
she's out she's out that's that took
like Lisa left eye Lopes exit strategy
everything everything must go
that is so that's an amazing thing to
find out via a letter too yeah oh this
is a [ __ ] up letter yeah wait what
I've been watching someone read that
letter whatever it is man you're
overreacting what happened she tore my
house down and sold all my stuff well
that's crazy that's not that's not
normal is she left guy she's Lisa left
eye Lopes oh no that's a bad yeah she
you know she she said it was because the
job right and Harlan quote well after a
while I got so homesick to see my family
and especially the children that I
thought up a plan to kidnap them cool no
logical next step it's where you go
where you go yep
apology or kidnap it's easier to kidnap
you eat less crow if you kidnap hundred
percent I mean the look on her face when
you're apologize
give her the saddest word we can't give
her this a turnout look I want to see is
her knowing her kids have been stolen
tell you what I might give away a bunch
of that furniture on the way out to
those kids and throw the Ottoman to the
neighbors
so quote a heavy wooded area was on one
side of the home in Jasper my plan was
to lie in them woods until the children
came out to play then I'd pick him up
and head for the railroad station is
anyone keeping track of the possible
trauma this causes children like hey our
dad's been lying and leaves and now he's
stealing us so he waited in the woods
for a whole day but the kids did not
come outside damn it
so Harlan decided to just go up to the
house knock on the door and upon seeing
him the kids should play so upon seeing
him his wife immediately took him back
weird weird chronology well it's one of
those things where it's why you suffered
in dirt and twigs I missed you I want
here where the forest I'm sorry I gave
away our bed yeah there's no house yeah
no I tore it all to hell I was really
busy yeah that's not what you should do
no I let my emotions get the best it's a
house well you're the level-headed one
because you just came back just to say
I'm sorry I just you know I was the one
who overreacted I did a crazy thing yeah
you manned up I just came here just to
be in the woods
I'd nobody would say that whatever did
twigs but you are gonna steal them no of
course not I wasn't stealing yes
the porter case yes so he then the
family moves to Tennessee because he got
a fireman job okay so this time he's
like why don't ya oh go to Tennessee
wouldn't that make a ton of sense to all
of us
but then he pretty quickly got fired
because he got in a fistfight with an
engineer okay which happens sure yeah of
course so they moved to Little Rock
Arkansas where Harlan got another
fireman job okay and he also started
studying law via correspondence right
through letters like you're supposed to
as you're supposed to get a law degree
you do it through letters letter law
letters letter of the law letters from
lawyers or letters huh pertaining to
letters come may have law on them and
that's uh that's how it works
okay yeah well I guess that's how my dad
got his law degree and they just from
what I remember he's not a lawyer no
right his dog watchers say Sarah
Watchers Walker he walks in also [ __ ]
yeah a sort of a dog lawyer he's a dog
boy your honor that's my case Rob ruha
throw a bunch of little bacon strips on
the gun we should get out of here I
think this is what we call a hung jury
so so he's studying law via letters I
don't know what it means either but sure
he's reading a bunch of letters about
laws I'm sure back then you just see
some of the magazine you sign up for it
you get sent things to study the law
yeah one day a train jumped the track
nearby where he lived and he went and
used his new legal ex-presidents The
Dukes of Hazzard it wasn't just a trade
he uses new legal expertise to help the
injured victims get fair compensation
from the railroad company
okay which he works for okay so that's
so they were not
happy really did that they were like
you've been reading letters Harland and
they fired out okay if you can imagine I
don't know why yeah well yeah I think I
get it so now I believed he was supposed
to be a lawyer okay and hire them again
to practice in the justice of the peace
court in Little Rock which didn't
require passing the bar right well and
also he's got eight letters yeah he's
got all the more I mean yes point could
have a lie yeah so he worked minor cases
he was once arrested for attempting
assault and battery for trying to beat
up his own unruly client with a chair
he's a little bit of a temper right he's
usually not a good look in the courtroom
to attack your client with a chair well
this is the early nineteen hundreds
still it's not a good look like I feel
like the jury is like I think that I
don't like either of these guys maybe it
makes you the makes your client see more
sympathetic it could be a brilliant
technique you're right it could be
they're just like both the lawyers just
the worst we feel really bad for him not
guilty Harlan got a case he thought he
could easily win but then the judge
ruled against him this left his client
bankrupt and Harlan got no money
now the Arkansas State Senate at the
same time was considering a bill to
severely limit the powers of the justice
of the peace court so Harlan was so
angry about the case that he just lost
that he went and testified in the Senate
in favor of the bill he using the case
he just lost as an example of the court
miscarrying justice and to be clear
Harlan you were attacked one of your
clients with a chair oh yes I saw funny
stories he looked me in the eyes well
that is droll thank you you're all right
where we should prior recess okay so the
bill passed okay great news Harlan quote
I began to realize it wasn't as smart as
I thought you see maybe I made a big hit
at the hearings but I'd knocked myself
out of a job yeah I mean yeah how does
it sound like you had a lot of time to
probably process what he was doing
yeah I think he was mad okay so he's
lawyer himself out of a law job that's
right right was he gonna read letters
about next medicine will he move the
family back to Indiana okay
he held a bunch of different jobs we've
been nice if we had a house here well
it's on it's on the ground well would be
nice and maybe some furniture like a bed
or something oh my god let it go yeah I
will let it go just like you let go all
of our bedding and our pillows and our
couches you were gonna steal the
children I what I I was napping Italy
for a day yes for a day what do you
think I didn't let him outside well why
would I yeah I'm gonna play the kids
idiot Oh
he worked at a flour mill at an
insurance company as a ferry boat
operator mm-hmm
he sold lighting systems for farms he
was a secretary of the Chamber of
Commerce of Columbus he was a Michelin
tire sounds you want to just go through
what he didn't do is that in a shorter
list yeah he goes through a lot jobs
okay so the Michelin tire salesman job
ended in 1926 now what happened was his
son's Model T sedan sometimes needed to
be pulled to start his son's model okay
okay right so he would hook up to his
car and pull it and sure I would get it
going right it's a good model yeah yeah
so Harlan tied the car to his and he
started pulling it and they went over a
bridge at Hickman Creek you know Hickman
Creek yeah obviously it's a swinging
bridge that a bit built for horse
carriages so it's so it's super scary
and treacherous yep should have just
been a regular [ __ ] yeah
so not cars on the bridge when they're
on it one of the cables snapped and both
cars fell 42 feet they're both inside
the car Jesus they both survived you
know scrapes bruises and whatnot
cars are destroyed so now they need
another car to kind of pull those guys
right if those girls you can see where
this is gonna go it's that's beginning
of parade so he got fired after that by
Michelin because he couldn't afford a
new car and needed a car to be a tire
sure sure
he retired he and Josephine had a third
child Mildred definitely time to expand
the household well yeah just so secure
yeah so after 15 years in indiana harlan
bought a struggling gas station in
Nickelsville kentucky quote like a rich
area yeah quote up to this time I had
always worked for somebody else this
service station gave me the first
opportunity I had to control my own
destiny
he opened earlier and closed later than
his competitors he washed customers cars
and repaired tires for free and the
station became very popular okay here we
go and then they get a Great Depression
hit alright now if memory serves that
was good for good it's called great yeah
the Great Depression aim yeah it should
be the terrible day yeah most depression
is fantastic is amazing I haven't eaten
in days
this is a Great Depression so we are
having a hell of a time of the
depression he's forced to sell the gas
station but the Shell Oil Company and
heard how successful a station had been
and hired him to run a new gas station
in Corbin Kentucky okay they were two of
the guests finally our heroes step in
that's right there are two other gas
stations in town one one by Matt Stewart
the other by a man named McVeigh Harlan
said McVeigh was quote one of them old
mountain boys he had a pet pig beside
the corner of the service station and
kept water in a puddle so the pig could
wallow in it well this is I we now have
a leader for my favorite person it's a
different a man who pig puddles yeah
gotta have a big problem yeah McVeigh
had the best location in town for a gas
station he got most of the traffic from
the highway so he's right off the
highway uh-huh
Harlan was very nice to McVeigh when
Shell offered Harlan a second air
compressor he gave it to me
okay because he didn't have one okay and
when m'q when McVeigh retired a short
while later he offered Harland the
location okay interesting
so Harlan moved to the what about the
pig is the pig I don't think I assume
think they took his Pig interesting that
would be [ __ ] and I'll take your Pig I
agree the picture go Highland moved to
the the McVeigh lot and then he went
around and paid it adds on all the barns
with a hundred miles of Corbin and he
chose barns rather than billboards
because quote down in that country
hunters was always shooting up roadside
signs but no hunter is gonna come along
and shoot the dot over the I in the hole
or the oh no one there's a mule inside
that's that's that's good letter lawyer
logic that's right he thought it through
yep yep nuts relatable era as well some
at Stuart's gas station is now is only
competitor okay what does he have a
horse Minnie well we know we don't know
about his animal situation teacup pig no
we're not sure so one day Stuart painted
over one of Harlan's barn ads now he is
he just he's painting it can you just
paint on people's barns I think he gets
permission okay that's it that's good so
Stuart pates over one Harlan's furious
and he threatened to quote blow his
goddamn head off okay so this guy goes
from zero to sixty I kind of noticed
yeah you should just steal his kids yeah
that's how you do what he does yeah
that's a good play so he went back and
repainted his out on the barn over
Stuart so are we having a paint off
seems like it Wow
a little while later Harlan was meeting
with two shale oil district managers at
his gas station when they heard Stuart
was back painting over the ad again oh
my god so they grab their guns Jesus
it's [ __ ] serious business man you
know paint over dudes ad just seems a
little month as the Mules inside I don't
know if you want guns and Harlan and the
managers headed for at the barn
Stuart's up on the ladder when he saw
them coming he jumped off and started
shooting at them
okay he killed one of the shell my god
my god but sis dark-dark stop and Harlan
and the others shell manager shot back
and they hit Stuart in the shoulder
Harlan on the matter you explained to a
man's family that he was killed over a
barn add it back van barn hazard
[ __ ] serious yeah they'd be like your
husband was killed over barn and they'd
be like okay I guess well at least he
died doing what he loved so they they
went to trial but they were it was
determined they'd shot back and acted in
self-defense okay Stuart was found
guilty of murder
yes you murdered a man yeah tears later
he was murdered in prison supposedly by
a deputy sheriff who had been paid off
by the dead managers family
so that's Jesus well you gotta have
justice yeah sure yep yeah
Harlan now had the only gas station in
town yeah well that's how it works
Hey shoot the other guy and then he dies
in prison yep let's just say you drew it
up that's the oil playbook that's right
his gas station is a huge hit open 24
hours a day
Harlan always want the extra mile first
customers he even drove around need me
to kill someone I'll do that I have a
track record of being involved in
murders a couple degrees away but I
still don't have a problem with it you
want me to do your windshield check the
tires and shoot that kid in the backseat
yeah you can actually leave the
windshield
okay just boom there you go thank you yo
yo let me clean off the backseat
actually now that I look at it I would
like the back seat a little cleaned up
he's all over there yeah he's I really
know how to do
who knows who knew he was full of so
much goo oh my god I want a boy pop see
really pops it's my first boy pop yeah
come on go inside and have a
sarsaparilla
all right I'm crying inside all right
clean the back and make sure you get all
the little parts out of the divot yes
yes will ma'am
thank you if that order was wrong so he
would drive around the state to check
which roads were being repaired so he
could tell customers what routes to take
okay that's a pretty good pretty good
service sure yeah yeah we
just foiled now it's like yeah obviously
ways ways looking about word of mouth
about the station spread beyond Corbin
truckers became about a large part of
his business in 1932 is said Harlan
junior died at 20 years old due to
complications from tonsillitis mmm the
great killer yep the 8 the early
nineteen hundred's version of AIDS is
what was it terrible no but I was
recently for whatever reason I may have
been on Wikipedia searching which MLB
players had died while they were players
and a lot of them died of a really
common [ __ ] really yeah but you did
reveal that you're a real weirdo I mean
sometimes you go down a hole yeah
sometimes it starts to come to bed Dave
hold on I just got a check something
real quick oh that's crazy sometimes you
sometimes someone sends you a link of
that a Cincinnati player went to sleep
during a game on the field and then you
look that up and then all of a sudden
you're looking at which players died
during baseball that's quite a leap we
should get back to this way but you and
I have to maybe need to attack yeah yeah
yeah okay that's fair
so the the death of the son puts a
pretty big strain on the marriage sure
Harlan becomes a huge fixture in Corbin
he joins the Rotary Club he started
volunteering in an orphanage and
Alcoholics Anonymous he didn't drink he
wasn't a drinker he volunteered as a
County inspector and became friends with
a lot of poor residents in the town okay
he started a side business delivering
babies at low cost for families who
couldn't afford real doctors huh sure
yep no just keep going Dave what about
well he owns a gas station he knows he
knows what you're saying no he doesn't
he knows law and he worked on a train
yeah he worked on a train he was fired
he was insurance salesman yes he learned
about the law from letters he we did a
lot of jobs so a lot of that just
translate
you're a baby a baby is someone yeah
that's all we're saying the opposite
thing but it all comes together yes sir
it does not do that freak we're agreeing
we are disagreeing quote I got me a lard
bucket and puts mush is a terrible start
this is we're talking well let me lard
your lady up but then maybe I'll jump
out her tummy until the thing goes
squish squish and hits the pillar what I
got me a lard bucket and puts in my
shears and God hears woods
well first I'm gonna tremor and then
we're gonna larder and soon that's where
the umbilical cord is still or the Sheep
listen when you start with a bucket of
lard assuming you're gonna see him the
umbilical cord is pretty ambitious if
you if you tell me you've got a bucket
of lard and shears I'm like Friday night
let's go let's do it
this is perfect oh I don't even think
you need the lard this year's will do
but however you want to do it doctor no
I'm a gas station attendant
I got me a lard bucket and puts in
machines and gauze and Vaseline and kept
it ready when I got a call I would grab
that bucket and take off I had at least
one baby and then Hills named after me
that's okay so one baby lived for sure
for sure but then he quit delivering a
children after he delivered one who was
conceived at a wedlock that's what did
it yeah yeah okay or Tory greased one up
too much I think he greased one up too
much and it just shot out of the window
I assumed he was using the lard without
grease the shoe by the way I'm picturing
large with like a brush and he's just
kind of painting around oh yeah that's
what does it yeah
but he's just sort of like how they used
to hang up wallpaper that's what I
picture or they're probably Halle
learned a Krupp cop was arresting
tourists in town on fake charges the
local justice of the peace and county
attorney would then convict them and
they'd split the fines with the cop got
a racket go yep
Corbin getting a bad reputation would
hurt his business so using his legal
expertise he larded up the bars and
gripped the pay people out of the cell
he larded up the people harlot maid
forms explaining how tourists could ask
for a change of trial venue hmm and the
county attorney then sued him for
practicing law without a license even
though he was just offering legal tips
right so Harlan them requested a change
of venue as I read in his own pamphlet
and they were like where did you learn
oh my god he's a genius he's been
reading letters and the charges were
dismissed okay but the racket continued
so Harlan put up a 16-foot tall sign
outside the gas station that read quote
avoid Corbin and Whitley County
constable and fee grabbers may get you
Walter Ray Smith County Attorney
receives 40 percent of all fines this is
I think this is out of the business
model this I mean he's you know he's
going he's yes yeah he's got a fight
he's got a fight so Smith sued Harlan
for 20,000 okay they settled that
settled out of court but this was this
whole scenario the whole thing was
written up in newspapers in Kentucky and
in all the neighboring states
so he's a hero well he got tons of
publicity right so it just makes the gas
station more popular right so business
starts booming okay interesting PR yep
and he got an idea he would combine foot
and he would combine food and gas
so truckers would only have to make one
stop mm-hmm so this is where boiled
peanuts can breath this is when gas
stations started to serve ache
sandwiches now it's the rolling hot dogs
in a 7-eleven well we
should thank this guy for being the guy
who gave us the rolling hotdogs in the
7/11 and diarrhea
big time yeah I mean anytime behind
someone at a 7-eleven who's like also I
just doesn't wings like buddies buddy a
nothing it's fyssas this is their their
everywhere else is better to go
it's [ __ ] death yeah look at that
that hotdogs covered in everything mmm
they don't look like hotdogs their
hotdogs covered in just [ __ ] yeah I call
them pigs in a puddle
that's a call back you I know it was
come on I know I was giving you nothing
for it yeah I need you Aaron can you
step in so so he cleared out a small
room in the gas station and filled it
with this family's dining-room table in
six chairs
okay so restaurants works yeah it's not
me sharing a chairs in the table so is
he is he talking about selling food he's
talking about having family suppers in
the back when people are loading up he's
gonna make food and sell it okay and he
thinks he needs a table just because wow
you gotta have a place to sit for the
people exactly it's a restaurant right a
food or food or sitter place yes exactly
it's a food say he cooked up what do you
know how to cook biscuits string beans
and fried chicken mmm
word spread about the amazing fried
chicken this gas station got a
reputation as a dining spot okay he shut
down the gas station and opened the
Harlan cafe the gas station part is done
now he finished with the gas state the
this the people are coming for the food
so much okay
soon the restaurant was just raking in
money and in 1935 the Kentucky governor
gave Harlan the honorary title of
Kentucky kernel Oh what is going on no
what no what yeah this is this is like
learning about the origin story of
grimace
okay so he gets that for his
contribution to the state's cuisine and
then it's not a big deal to get that
title there are thousands of Kentucky
Colonels at that point sure he didn't
think much of it so in 1937 he bought
the lot next door and turned it into a
17 room motel okay so now he's got a
motel and restaurant it's called the
chicken in which are called the
Heartland Court and cafe okay
huge hit okay part of that was because
of Jim Crow okay Jim Crow was actually a
pet crow that an early motel guest had
owned and Harlan liked the crows antics
and bought the crow from the customer
wait what a guy was staying in the hotel
motel and he had a pet crow Holiday Inn
and the heat and Harlan liked how wacky
the crow was so he bought them okay
it's another attraction for the people
try some fried crow doesn't talk that's
me talking I'm Harlan now so what what
so here's what blue crow would do the
customers reporters super smart super
sure that's very very smart so they
would people have put pennies in the
cuffs of their pants and Jim throw
really weird start yeah and racist and a
Jim Crow would run behind them trying to
grab the penny with his beak so that he
would chase them and try to grab the
penny out of their pant cuff so the
reason why it's named the crow is named
by rose it's black
oh right right but I can only say that
it's horrible racist yeah which is
normally the safe bet for this era you
wouldn't find if you didn't expect to
find that in Kentucky at this time no no
or or now no so if somebody didn't give
the crow a penny particularly if a woman
didn't Jim Crow would angrily peck at
their ankles so it's fun is it fun no
okay right just to be clear and once Jim
Crow snuck into a guest room while the
guest was at the cafe okay this is now
crossing a line as far as like what is
like this is now no longer
show this is robbery it's horrible
Harlan quote I'll be god damned if that
crow didn't get to sashay around the
room and see himself in the mirror and
when the sale this is a crazy theory
when the salesman got back to the room
it was a mess that Crowe torn up
everything to fight the other Crowe he'd
seen in the mayor the this is a
wackadoodle thing this his his the
colonel as we can now call this theory
is that the Crowe saw himself in the
mirror and is like I'm gonna destroy
this room to show that other Crowe
that's right okay crow fight yep
so Harlan after that and had to give Jim
Crow away okay there was also a donkey
out behind the motel for a while and to
amuse guests Harlan would bring them in
back where the donkey would hee-haw and
apparently this was a great bit ensure
people there wasn't TV so this is where
you've been what are we gonna watch
tonight we'll go watch it don't get
kicked me out where we'll be all up all
night with that adrenaline rush damn it
that was fun look at him oh man I I'm
exhausted from laughing and having a
good time
yeah me too story about when you saw the
donkey oh yeah okay so he's kid walks
yeah I walk around the building yeah and
the donkey like oh man I miss Kentucky
oh man what a great place I Steve it
second hand it's a winner
there was a racist crow oh well hated
women of course yeah a pretty great
place yeah this is that in this era
that's fun yeah
oh yeah for sure
so early 1939 a fire broke out in the
restaurant and it spread to the motel
most of it was destroyed but it was
insured
Harlan quote I got to thinking to myself
you can sleep a man only once in 24
hours but you can feed him three times
yes sort of so he built a hundred and
forty two seed restaurant
hotels gone okay what did he call this
establishment um Taco Bell that's right
the restaurant became a huge success
now Harland still was holding a grudge
against his wife for the time she left
him and tore down the house well I feel
like we buried that I feel like we
buried the hatchet on that he was still
holding on we did he didn't okay quote
her leave Nate out so much they did they
did quote her leaving me just because I
had lost a job had a cut in effect where
I love was young and tender when our
love was young and tender I guess I
never really got over it in 1948 after
39 years of marriage they divorced
mm-hmm Harlan would later write what
happened next quote I never intended to
marry again but after a year and a half
I began to lose buttons on my coat I
could sew them on but then my socks
needed darden and I couldn't darn socks
there's a tailor I realize I needed a
wife they need a tailor more life you
need a tailor Claudia had been one of
our early employees not love I heard
don't marry this poor person occasion to
observe her and knew how dependable she
was you need a tailor what her life was
and how industrious she was maybe read
some letters on how to sew so I proposed
to Claudia no and now my socks don't
have holes oh my god get the [ __ ]
Harland and sometimes I beg her through
a hole in my sock to show her what I
need fix it but actually that's not what
happened
okay that's his version our version is
like we just I don't never forget when
our eyes met and there was a sparkle off
the river and it just had a little twing
in the corner his on I knew he was the
one and then and then I handed her my
sock and then I started sewing up in his
love right there yeah
his daughter Margaret said Claudia was
his mistress and they had been together
before she came to work for right
Harlan quote the peace of our whole
family was altered by their affair
mother refused to accept that she alone
could not satisfy father's physical need
he needed a two-piece yeah I need a
double set yeah
the two-piece some sides yeah which from
the very beginning of their marriage had
seemed excessive to her so he'd like to
[ __ ] a lot sure his double [ __ ] they
call it in the business absolutely right
father
nevertheless had a libido which required
a healthy willing partner and he found
one in young Claudia mhm
so that's the real story okay Harlan's
life change because he had an infamous
dirty mouth okay he went to a National
Restaurant Association convention and
became friends with a Salt Lake City
restaurant owner named Pete Harmon okay
the Harlan told Harmon he was going to
go so after that howl until the HAR me
he was gonna go to a church convention
in Australia okay great stuff quote of
course I didn't tell him that my reason
for goin was to try to get some
inspiration to overcome my cousin he
what he's going to Austria honest
Australian Church to learn how to not
cuss well it's not church's church
convention right so a lot of church
people I don't know really is the right
place to go to night Fox not a [ __ ]
sway might you come all this bloody why
to try quit swearing now facts not a
problem
turn your [ __ ] Bibles to pay now see
what you do is you have a couple these
bees and then you beat them in with a
bloody Bible
that's the move I didn't particularly
care for the meetings but I did think
with all those pious people around
ministers missionaries and such like
then I might be able to get the kind of
help I needed
well the truth is you couldn't you've
never been able to find a bunch of
religious fanatics in America that's
right so you have to sometimes out
Australia yeah so he's so he's going to
Australia and the guy Harmon in Salt
Lake City so stop by my restaurant stop
by in hand it's not like sitting on your
way to Australia sure it's a natural way
it's a straight shot so he crazy - not
yeah you're going right by it that's
right so he did okay and there Harlan
cooked his first batch of his Fried
Chicken if I chicken that he ever had
done outside of his restaurant okay
Harmon loved it and talked Harlan into
letting him a licensed the recipe Harlan
would get four cents for every chicken
sold okay seems like a [ __ ] deal that's
kind of free money I mean yeah but it's
also like yeah I mean licensing is
really free money right but still you
gotta have more free money well I'm
waiting how much is the chicken cause
back that's true assuming it wasn't
eight cents he stopped by on his way
back from Australia two weeks later it
can't be two weeks later but whatever
yeah two years and he found a
seven-foot-tall sign touting the new
name Kentucky Fried Chicken the manager
came up with a slogan it's finger lickin
good
he did that hmm Harmon had Harland
record a radio ad for Kentucky Fried
Chicken you keep licking your fingers
you ain't gonna stop it's the first time
he had promoted his food on Mike
in 1953 the Eisenhower administration
came up with the the interstate highway
system and after a few years news came
that the highway in front of the Harlan
cafe would be replaced with the
interstate 5 which would bypass Corbin
entirely
Oh No so most of the restaurants
business were travelers on the highway
this is this is where they invented
roadside barns or IEDs ideas exactly he
saw the writing on the wall and decided
to sell the restaurant two years before
he'd been offered one hundred sixty four
thousand dollars but now he couldn't
find a buyer in 1956 he sold the
restaurant for seventy-five thousand at
auction he used the money to pay taxes
and outstanding bills and Harland
Sanders is now 65 years old living off
his monthly Social Security check Wow
okay America yeah
Harlan made had made some similar
franchising agreements for his chickens
that he'd done with Harmon better you
know half a dozen or so around the
country it's not a ton of money not
making him rich or anything obviously
but there's potential he sees potential
in franchising right so he's still
business minded well does he 65 yeah
okay 65 all right without a restaurant
Harlan and Claudia dove into the
franchising business cloudy mixed the
herbs and spices and shipped them off to
franchises which ensured the rest people
to remain a secret
uh-huh Harlan across the country looking
for new franchisees he would spend days
at a restaurant promoting his chicken
technique cooking for customers and
often sleeping in the back of his car he
would just go to arrest what he would
just drive around the restaurants and
try to talk them into doing his
essentially licensing an acoustic guitar
player but with spices this next one
it's called wings he's essentially a
shitty cover band right okay so it's 65
Stephen is [ __ ] like the ultimate
nightmare it's hard enough to sleep when
you're 65 in a bed yes but he needed he
needed a marketing scheme to set his
brand apart and he remember his honorary
Kentucky Colonel ship and began going by
Colonel Sanders here we go here we go he
sported a white moustache and goatee he
started using a cane holding a cane
wearing a light just like old Satan if
he had right
white suit white shirt black string tie
black shoes while Colonel Santos is
known to Colonel Sanders was known to be
a nice guy he had anger flare-ups sure
he was known to swear to employees and
sometimes at the employees and
restaurants his chicken was franchised
it sure well he's an old man yeah yeah
that's right yeah he wasn't one to back
down or let stuff get by a restaurant he
and Claudia were eating at this isn't
even a franchisee he's just about the
seasoning at another restaurant while he
was served undercooked eggs under yeah
what over-medium see what this is going
well he had asked for them to be flipped
over and cooked on both sides uh-huh
they didn't come that way shower running
sure so he requested the weight just
they should be cooked more and the
waitress returned really quickly and
Harland wasn't buying that they had been
cooked he flipped them over and found
out that the cook had not cooked them at
all but just flipped over the eggs on
the plate good how about go [ __ ]
yourself
so Colonel Sanders stormed into the
kitchen holding the plate and said to
the cook quote you just slipped them you
didn't do it you said you gonna do you
son of a [ __ ] you think you're smart
turning those eggs over on my plate he
threw the eggs at the cook and hit him
in the chest Jesus Christ the cook came
at him with a knife and harlots hardly
picked up a stool and backed out of the
kitchen swearing at the cook the whole
way I'm gonna live tamer my way out of
here the cook eventually stopped his
charge and went back into the kitchen in
Harlan and Claudia ate somewhere else oh
okay but the silver lining is that cook
now listened when orders got sent back
no [ __ ] yeah it was like ooh oh you know
I'll flip it over I almost stabbed the
guy when he threw eggs at my chest so
I'm gonna just flip these Kentucky Fried
Chicken spread across the country mm-hmm
they're new franchises in Indiana and
they're there in Indiana at a new
franchise there was a young chef cook
whatever named Dave Thomas what are like
the this is like the Bill Walsh coaching
tree
here we got Davey Thomas working it back
and a little man named Jeff McDonald aka
Ron I'm Ron McDonald lucky to meet Carl
jr. how are ya my dad was big into this
Harley became his mentor and Thomas
invented the rotating chicken buckets
that were outside KFC restaurants
decades Thomas helped provide some
failing KFC's and was given money for
that and he used the money to start his
own chain of hamburger restaurants named
after his daughter Wendy
it's like Superfriends Colonel Sanders
magnetic personality combined with his
chicken recipe were a hit the family had
enough money to move to a five-bedroom
house near Louisville by 1960 there were
200 KFC's in the US by 1963 there were
600 franchisee KFC outlets in North
America in October 1963 Harland Colonel
Sanders sari was approached by a
longtime friend named John Y Brown jr.
Brown a partner his father wanted to buy
KFC but Colonel Sanders said a sale was
out of the question and brown kept
pushing telling him the business would
fall apart after he died and his kids
would not get what they deserved
cool tactic this way they would get cash
right okay right yeah so the Browns also
got franchisees around the country to
tell Harland they wanted him to sell and
they did that by promising the
franchisees stock in the company once he
sold sure that kept oh that's cool for
sure yeah highlight eventually decided
to sale was the right move quote I
realized how the popularity of Kentucky
Fried Chicken was growing right over me
and mashing me flat yep time to sell
that's what they say I just couldn't
keep up with it yep that's definitely
time to sell when you're like this is so
out of control fiscally I'm out I'm out
in March 1964 he sold KFC to Brown and
his partner for two million dollars
stock shares Christ's stock shares and a
continuing role as a KFC advisor and
brand ambassador for 40 K a year my god
that's a good deal for back then that's
a lot of money for back up but still I
know it's not a lot but he got stock and
he got he gets 40 K
year things how about some
professionalism my sister she says not
my problem I don't know what that's
about
doesn't sound great what a nice little
curtain peel back that is that's my
sister you're not my brother
anyway 1965 I'm sure it's about my dad
so but then he gives his stock shares
that he got back in exchange for
ownership of KFC Canada franchises
interesting play so in 1965 he and
Claudia moved to Ontario so he's banking
that we got some piggies up north that's
right yeah and there are we know just
piggy says hey I'll tell you what thanks
to America there's Piggy's huh we're
just piggies and puddles that's right
sorry brown hired a PR team who created
in a national ad campaign featuring
Colonel Sanders he became a minor
celebrity appearing on The Tonight Show
and Lawrence Welk Show and others he
made more money and became a major
philanthropist around this time Colonel
Sanders became very religious I'm father
Sanders now in 1967 he was baptized in
the Jordan River imagine seeing that
it's not the colonel the colonel getting
dunked in that River
I see him he's a beautiful bacon a lot
but he's right before me I have touched
the Lord not telling you his love his
finger licking pies he became close
friends with Billy Graham and Jerry
Falwell or God say yeah [ __ ] right we
liked him till now yeah it is a good run
yeah
at one point he went to see a doctor
because he had an impacted bowel what do
you know impacted bowel is guessing it's
severe constipation yeah there's
something in there that's at that point
like a rock and you got to get it taken
out
if there's ever been an advertisement
for KFC it's that come on down and get
our everlasting bowel ball a while a
pooping
well KFC if you get our nine piece
bucket and a side of our mashed potaters
you're gonna find that you're not gonna
have that problem anymore [ __ ] will come
out of your ears you'll be sweating your
poo so the doctor finds that he has a
colon polyp Harlan claimed in his
autobiography that he cured the colon
polyp with prayer yep that's how most
polyps go that's how they go yeah quote
last night a minister prayed that God
would heal me and he did imagine if your
god no no no no no you have you know
it's let's just say hypothetically this
is a real situation yeah and and God is
up in the sky and she's very busy she's
got a lot to do a lot on her plate mhm
and then there's just these prayers are
coming in non-stop
and then you got so much to do I mean
the world the universe you're overseeing
your allknowing hmm and there's someone
down there praying to get a polyp out of
them I love that guy I'm gonna kill him
but I love me I mean he's dead but he's
great I mean he's so into me you kill
him because you're like I want this guy
by my side yeah this is hilarious he's
super in him and I can't wait till he
gets up here I'm like guess what what it
doesn't work that's not how it works
that's why I made doctors [ __ ] idiot
oh I never made fall wills ah well they
they're people they're saying different
they're not great they're not great oh
you love his finger like one of them and
his wife of [ __ ] a pool boy Yeah
right well yeah I was looking the other
way on that okay yeah in January 1968
Harlan invited FBI director Jada who
were to celebrate his 80th birthday what
a list
you are we I mean this is like you are
hitting some real chips you've got the
fall wells we're talking about Colonel
Sanders now he's hanging out with Hoover
he wrote him quote I do believe us old
folks can show those young people what
celebrating is all about yeah right and
we know Hoover did I mean yeah yeah yeah
quote oh sorry
Harlan had previously written Hoover in
1960 to compliment his handling of the
quote San Francisco riots he was
probably talking about Black Friday
protests which were demonstrations
against the House Subcommittee on
unamerican activities so Harlan
basically said he really liked Hoover's
work yeah and who didn't yeah everybody
harlan's FBI report begins quote Colonel
Harland Sanders Colonel Harland of
Sanders F F F is like a game of Thrones
like fast Oh Sanders I am Ireland of
Sanders we've come down from the chicken
Mountains but can I just point out that
they're calling him Colonel and his name
is not colonel the Colonel's he's not an
actual curve and the affair party the
comb curls I got a colonel it's there's
no chicken army oh you don't know army
of chickens quote Colonel Harland
Sanders has not been the subject of an
FBI investigation and then that sentence
is followed by two paragraphs of
redacted text so makes me think he
definitely was never under surveillance
so at one point J edgar Hoover's FBI was
investigating kernels it sounds like it
yeah
is it finger licking good
in 1968 the very racist Alabama
politician George Wallace considered
Harland Sanders as his running mate for
his third party Pro segregationist
presidential campaign oh my god what how
great of a dollop would that be he'd run
there is an alternate universe where he
eventually became president Oh
[Laughter]
we have I mean we've never had a
president who liked KFC more oh
absolutely and I'll guarantee you
Trump's dealt with an impacted bowel Oh
100% he is an impacted mom he is sorry
you have a Trump ah don't worry I'll
just pray Jesus loves me
he's a close friend even though Harlan
was a major contributor to Wallace's
campaign in his autobiography he claimed
that he is not racist writing quote I'm
not racist I just had to say you'll find
most non racist people have made that
statement in their life his daughter
said he liked Wallace because of his
other not racist policy yeah yeah for
sure yeah yeah that's why you I mean
that's a that's a blip you're like I
loves up polyp on the ass of policy I
love Wallace's tax policies there's also
the thing where he just constantly talks
about segregation how bad black people
are but other than that again the tax
plan yeah really good we're good
critical down in 1971 Brown sold
Kentucky Fried Chicken to food
distribution company hew blind which
district distributed smirnoff vodka that
obviously did not please Colonel Sanders
he also didn't make any money from the
sale because he didn't own any stock
stock for but he's making enough money
off the candidate Isis
Harlan thought the quality of KFC then
went downhill mostly because the giant
corporation was using cheaper
ingredients to save money in 1974 he
sued
Hulan he blind who he called quote booze
hounds he claimed they weren't following
his secret recipe and then his
reputation was suffering as a result
sure he told the Milwaukee Journal quote
I'm not too proud of my name being
associated with some of my restaurants
everybody thinks I'm a I'm Kentucky
Fried Chicken they don't know these
other fellows who really run things I
only want to find out how much in my
body and soul they own oh my god really
the headline for that should be fake
Colonel worried about name
[Music]
alright there's that the suit was
settled out of court but Harlan got a
million dollars ok the next year he
opened a rep because basically they
couldn't have their spokesman suing them
it's a [ __ ] nightmare of course they
had to pay him off no
imagine if Ronald McDonald was suing
McDonald's can we get there please I'll
do anything I've been so good the next
year Colonel Sanders open a restaurant
in Shelbyville called Harlan Colonel
Harlan dinner house so he is now like no
now he's owned fried chicken place okay
that is my husband they've changed the
formula so much that it doesn't taste
like his chicken II brush so he's like
I'm gonna open up my chicken place right
he's gonna put himself out of business
hopefully KFC was upset what was
upsetting I don't know that it's called
[ __ ] you Kentucky Fried Chicken okay we
need to give him more money um so they
got upset and so he renamed it Colonel's
lady's dinner house well now that is a
name that makes sense I was I was
worried we were gonna get a little more
into the questionable territory but
obviously we've landed on a good one
colonel ladies chicken house still lady
chickens KFC still sued okay Wow so
they're really Harlan counter sued them
for 122 million my number cream and KFC
was interfering with his business that's
right now the case was settled out of
court and no one knows for what but the
name was changed to glaze Claudius
Sanders dinner Claudius Sanders dinner
so even with the lawsuit Harlan remained
part of Kentucky Fried Chicken he was
still active in promoting Kentucky Fried
Chicken around the world well into his
80s at age 87 he testified against
mandatory retirement before the us
Subcommittee on Aging he was also very
active in the bedroom his daughter said
once during a conversation there was a
lull and then
Harlen randomly bert blurted out that he
continued to have sex past his 83rd
birthday what that's that's how you
break a low your daughter that's how you
break a little quiet don't say it it's
quiet don't say it don't say that's very
you know I'm still [ __ ] god damn it I
can't believe it send that to you my
precious daughter but I'm still [ __ ]
I left to come on her face I feel weird
well dad we're probably gonna get going
have some chicken no I don't want to
touch anything you've touched special
sauce no you're a dirty dirty man
I shouldn't have said that thing about
[ __ ] right without question
take care of pops eat Christmas I'm
still [ __ ] didn't shut that window
I know hurry get at the car get the kids
of the car one time I got pegged they
went in me that's where that pilot came
fro do you know what it is holy that's
where they put it at you mash your
potatoes see ya
Krissi I'll soon I can't sit down I'll
to cut him a button from getting peg so
much by your mom
you know I drink your mom's piss once
they mention that I'm sorry we just
didn't have nothing to talk about
another throw to somewhere you have a
variety of sexual experiences i watch
Dave Thomas [ __ ] your mom and a barn
that's where he came up with the idea
for the Baconator Don't Tell Wendy don't
let Wendy know any of this but I'm
Wendy's real dad I've seen Ronald
McDonald 69 your mom while I was
whacking off into a curtain
I don't want to go along junk silver
huge honey where'd you go if she left
two days ago oh my god I've exclaiming
out here in the forties for two days
holy [ __ ] I feel weird yeah yeah yeah oh
boy so he would make surprise visits to
KFC locations you didn't find the fluid
up to his standards he would denounce it
and sometimes even throw it on the floor
sure so he's nobody's told him to stop
throwing three places now he just kind
of developed a tantrum quirk in 1978 he
went into a KFC in Bowling Green
Kentucky and after he ate he told a
local newspaper quote my god the gravy
is horrible they buy tap water for 15 or
20 cents a thousand gallons and then
they mix it with flour and starch and
end up with pure wallpaper paste Jesus
the owner then sued for defamation it's
amazing how much he's getting sued by
himself the case was dismissed
obviously the company's in a tough spot
because the kernel was the face of KFC
but he's still talking she's like 90 now
we just wait this one out
KFC's public relations chief during the
latter part of the 1970s was a black man
and he said Harlan liked to play a joke
when they traveled together oh god no
quote in the case with me traveling with
the colonel I always sat in back believe
it or not and he sat up front with the
driver and what he would do when he got
to the motel where we stayed he jumped
out of the car and ran to go to the back
to open the door for me and then he'd
run ahead to the hotel and guide me
through the door and he would carry the
bags okay once doorman said to the
publication chief and Colonel Sanders I
know the guy who opened the door is
Colonel Sanders and Harlan said quote
that's my son but we don't talk about
that so maybe not as racist or having
like a good sense of humor I don't know
it's not simply making fun of the times
right yes definitely blowing people's
minds so there's a
George Wallace but then sure I'm sorry
I'm not over the Jim Crow I know and
this guy really liked them I don't know
yeah it's complicated yeah yeah no but
overall I'd say he's probably racist
yeah and a couple years ago the CEO Papa
John said he should be able to use the
racial slur there is because Colonel
Sanders used to use it oh is that what
is justification yeah that's what he
said he no longer works at Papa John's
yeah that is the best but that was his
justification what yeah yeah peep yes
that's right good point Papa John's yeah
oh yeah sorry Papa John oh is it is it
2017 he said that unlike a conference
call yeah yeah and then and then went
back down Yeah right no and then was
like what do you guys mean Oh would
continue for chickens bad now this guy
is a real piece on December 16th 1980 at
age 90 Harland Sanders died of pneumonia
in Louisville Kentucky after his funeral
his body lay in state at the Kentucky
State Capitol Wendy's you know that and
the the will asked for him to be deep
fried oh god that would be so [ __ ]
amazing yeah that would be the best
thing ever and that's why I'm always
gonna miss my dad god I smell good he's
gonna be delicious
Wendy's obviously founded by David
Thomas is the fourth largest food chain
in the US the 11 herbs and spices in KFC
chicken recipe are still a closely
guarded trade secret there are over
20,000 KFC locations a hundred and
thirty countries around the globe making
it the fourth largest fast-food chain in
the world one country is Thailand sort
of in 2013 it was revealed a KFC type
restaurant had opened in Bangkok looked
exactly like KFC with one small
difference it was called Colonel lady
chicken Colonel Sanders head was
replaced with the head of Hitler oh I'm
terribly sorry and the head restaurant
was named Hitler
well hey Thailand can we talk to you for
a minute what I want everyone out to
Google Thailand it Hitler because Hitler
is a big thing in Thailand
what a British expat said quote nobody
quite knows what to make of it I went in
for a bite last week what why would you
go who's going in I've got some fried
chicken what which was pretty good I
asked the guy behind the counter why it
was called Hitler he just shrugged his
shoulders and said the owners had
thought it was a good image what KFC's
parent company which is now young issued
a statement saying they found it
distasteful and we're considering legal
action a month later the restaurant had
changed his name to Cellini's come down
to Idi Amin's change this name to H ler
oh ok so fetter and there's the head
this little rotating Hitler oh my god
Colonel Sanders is currently being
played by different actors and ads
including Reba McEntire oh my god what
the hell Jesus God well quite a story
about the colonel yeah I'll tell you I I
think among you know all all fast food
places are pretty bad just because they
oh my god it's Hitler it's Hitler in
everything else is the same
it's just Hitler's head and then it's
the and then it's Colonel Sanders little
apron and his little outfit and it just
plainly says Hitler what does the sign
say up front and there's a little sign
on the door sure it's anti oh god I
would hope that it says closed for
distaste but I think all the like all
that all those play all fast-food places
really for the most part are that that's
why I like Burger King now has the
impossible burger and I think that is
good in a way but I'm also like I don't
give Burger King or KFC or any of those
places my money because that they are so
bad to the treatment of animals is so
abysmal I know I went to I went
was so one impossible birthday and the
only place close was Fatburger and so I
got one that yeah but I feel bad eating
it there yeah well and and so I I've
been a vegetarian for mastani adult life
and there was a time when I was in LA
where I was pescetarian and I was like
that's I'm not gonna I'm gonna stop
eating fish tin or whatever I was with a
buddy
and he was editing something for us and
I was like cuz he was doing me a favor
so I was like yeah I'll come over and
we'll work on it he's like yeah just
grab me some KFC on the way over I was
like okay yeah so I went I had to go buy
KFC I went and bought him like you know
twelve piece whatever and we were
sitting in his little office and he's
editing and I'm sitting there and I'm
like and that was the day I start eating
chicken again really yeah for like a
year
okay so I'm a kid god I'm probably ten
and after I have a baseball game
sometimes my dad would take us to KFC
afterwards right and so he's in getting
the chicken and I'm outside and I'm in
the parking lot I'm just [ __ ] running
around or whatever and I go around back
Oh God you at bad start
[Laughter]
fast-food restaurants should not have
backs it should just be and there's like
a gated off area and it's where the
dumpsters are whatever and I open it up
what you open up the gated off area I'm
a kid yeah
and there are oil drums filled with
chicken carcasses oh oh and they are
gray as they've been yes tossed out and
are just [ __ ] sitting there and
they're piled high that's high as a
community or there was the right
spokesman and I never ate yeah I think I
don't think I've ever had fried chicken
again there there was a rumor about ten
years ago that I think is I believe has
been debunked but was pretty fantastic
where it was that KFC was and the truth
is that they the chickens they use I'm
sure full of antibiotics
but they there was a theory that they
had created a headless chicken called
animal 15 have you heard about this it
was and they and they basically called
it like a multi breasted multi wing like
you know for wing bird with no head but
it was just the meat was so volumous
that that's why it was kind of
genetically modified and created oh yeah
but that's close to what they are anyway
Oh totally no the chickens I mean yeah
I'm Jay they their breasts are so big
they can't stand up a lot of them have
trouble standing up and then there's the
thing where they eat each other well
they're the condition the conditions for
how you house animals for factory
farming is crazy
yeah and chicken coops is especially
like Tyson chicken and stuff like that
they now have it rules and and they I
mean talk about having like your foot on
the throat of farmers and stuff yeah
like these farmers are not allowed to
report to people about what's happening
and to the point now where they're so
worried about investigations that they
have their the chickens are not allowed
any light in the people in the coop yeah
yeah so that nobody said that no
investigators can actually look at and
see what's going on and then there was
actually a thing last week where they
were showing I Cameron what the [ __ ] the
company is called it's called Fair Oaks
I think oh yeah Fair Oaks factory farms
that the treatment of the animals is I
mean Marburg yeah it's what you would
expect but seeing seeing it is also very
very crazy and Bruce and a lot of those
chicken farmers are now becoming
vegetarians because they're so [ __ ]
mad and the chicken companies and and
we're talking like chicken farmers that
are essentially become indentured
servants no you have you hat your you
have no choice
yeah really if you're them because
you're like you did start in the meat
production business and it used and it
used to be with me production probably
when he started his business and stuff
you know these chickens were chickens
they were actually like chickens and
they were roaming and they you know and
you would eat them and that is a process
that people can make their own choice on
but it's become monsters it had it is it
is morphed now into torture yeah total
torture no the the way the animals are
treated is [ __ ] insane yes
and yes so now that fart and then of
course the farmers don't want to do it
so then they're forced to do it and it's
just crazy that whole system is [ __ ]
bananas yes well that's what happens
when six companies run everything I
think it's five and I think it might be
four I think it's pretty good yeah I do
think it's good you notice anything bad
I think about that now that I think
about it you're right it is a good fun I
made a good point it is a good point
yeah there's a finger looking good point
I'm not touching your pinkie even the
girl no all right we saw in cars we sent
cars go to doll podcast comm for tickets
to our shoe yes join us